[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wanted to do a pit stop with uh our
favorite football writer pat forty
covers football college football for
sports illustrated
big 10 had a
great month here but i'm curious as we
move forward
what happens next
with big ten sec
or does somebody else make a move there
just so people can understand is
anything imminent with big ten and scc
adding new schools
different rumor every day dan uh depends
who you listen to and who you're talking
to i don't think anything is imminent
but i've also got some people telling me
that within the next two weeks the big
ten could add schools
uh again i i it's hard to separate fact
from fiction there you know i think it
seems pretty clear notre dame is willing
to stand pat for the moment and they're
the big lever here so then it's a
question of can
washington or oregon or some other
combination of west coast schools make
themselves attractive enough to join the
big ten to get an offer and to go aboard
there and if that happens is the big 12
done and does the does the pac-12 done
and does the big 12 scoop up the schools
from the south i don't honestly know
where we're going but
if you're the big ten do you keep
rutgers and do you keep maryland do you
keep you know sort of these peripheral
schools here
while if going after florida state or
clemson or notre dame i mean is there
relegation here what what do you see
happening with these conferences
from what i've been told people be very
reluctant to you know kick out members
that they invited in uh
you know that it would be a bad look and
now hey college sports is not above bad
looks we've seen that
pursuit of the money but there is a kind
of a line there of just outright
betrayal of like we're just we're
getting rid of you uh secondly
they need some teams that can be beaten
right in every league not not
everybody's gonna go 12-0 you're gonna
need teams that are two and ten three
and nine
four and eight wait so a conference
a conference can't kick you out but you
can kick out a conference
yeah i mean you could do that texas
oklahoma did that ucla usc did that so
it it could happen i'm just curious if
and i've likened this to you know the
board game risk this is about just
rolling dice and going in and taking
over states taking over florida get
florida state central florida miami
that's what the scc might be looking at
but as far as
extrapolate this and and look at what
you think the timeline is and even when
greg sankey was with us a couple of
weeks ago he did talk about
you know maybe and nick saban talked
about relegation uh are we looking at
you know an afc and an nfc in college
football in your opinion in the next
five years
yeah i do think that yeah i've had a lot
of people say three to five years this
will all shake out and we will probably
have two mega conferences
of 18 to 20 teams each and everybody
else will see where you fit in now
there's also a school of thought that
somebody will form a third power
conference and if you can somehow get
enough schools from the acc to say
we want to break the grant of rights
we're leaving more than half uh then do
you go out and combine the best of the
aacc with the best of the big 12 with
the best of the remaining pac-12 and
that's the third power league i you know
i don't know the combo platter league if
it were if you will uh i i do still
think we are this is a big 10 sec power
play and it's going to end up with those
two as the dominant uh forces and even
more dominant in the next five years
give me the team the surprise team this
year that could be in the playoffs
i did you talk qualified as a surprise
i'm not sure if they do you know they
made the rose bowl last year but i think
they're poised to have a very good
season they open at florida september
3rd you win that game you get instant
credibility road win in the sec
then if you can go in and take care of
business in the pac-12 i kind of like
the utes to have a big season there yeah
but boy seeing them on the field against
ohio state in the rose bowl there was a
big separation in talent there
big separation speed no doubt about it
yeah look
hey somebody's gonna be the fourth team
in the playoff and they're probably
going to get trucked that's kind of been
the history of the play office whoever
there may be two or three good teams
there's rarely been four competitive
teams and two good semifinals all right
i know you're busy just wanted to check
in with you thank you pat
all right my pleasure dan we'll talk
more later pat 40 sports illustrated
national football writer